hello everyone today we'll go over the
step-by-step instructions to add an
additional key using this Pro key box
kit this kit is suitable for all key
lost situation or just programming an
extra key make sure to cut the keyblade
first before you begin programming this
kit is compatible with 2004 to 2015
Forex Explorer I will list compatibility
guide at the end of this
video this kit comes with the
aftermarket key the programmer tool and
the instruction manual if you have your
own unprogrammed key you can also
purchase the programmer tool separately
as an alternative option to save
money this tool will work on aftermarket
or the original key today we'll program
the aftermarket key with the kit once
you use this programmer it will lock to
your car Vin this means you can reuse it
many times in your vehicle but not in
any other vehicle for security
reason so to begin the process you need
to connect the tool to the OBD
Port once you connect it select the make
press enter select the model press enter
select the year of your
car then press enter next the screen
will say the whole process will take 10
minutes to
complete press enter to continue now you
need to insert the new key into the
ignition and turn to un position do not
start the car
then press
enter you'll hear a beeping sound to
indicate that the 10 minutes countdown
has
started we will cut the video short and
come back after 10 minutes
[Music]
after 10 minutes you'll hear a beeping
tone which means that the key chip
programming was
successful unplug the tool and let's
test the
key it is working and you're all done
with chip programming if you have more
key to program you need to repeat the
steps if your vehicle has remote head
key you'll need to program the remote
separately we'll demonstrate how to
program the remote portion in just a few
seconds ensure all key fob if available
are on hand before initiating the remote
portion programming procedure to begin
the remote programming
procedure ensure that the driver door is
left open next press unlock button
located on the driver door do not
depress brake pedal during this
programming procedure turn ignition from
off to run eight times within 10 seconds
with the eighth time ending in run door
locks will will cycle to confirm
programming mode within 20 seconds press
any button on first remote door locks
will cycle to confirm programming repeat
pressing any button of any more remotes
you want to program then turn ignition
to off locks will again cycle to
indicate end of programming
mode test all remotes and you're all
done
[Music]
hope you enjoyed the video thank you for
watching